If you know why the murder was set up and why the public figure made up the case, you
can narrow down the culprit as it is.The
culprit is in a position to know Detective Terada's height.
No position volatilization
Panning If a suspicious incident occurs in the city,
Detective Terada is a person who can be
helped if he moves.The
culprit is
Tina.
If you work for a police officer, it's not difficult to find out the position of the victim's head and feelings compared to the height of the door.
Even if you try to preserve evidence and call out a reliable shape, you will be suspicious and it won't
work.The only image of the culprit that can be inferred from the information that is currently available is a female police
officer.The motive for the murder can only be guessed.
Considering the amount of time it took to kill and the nature of the plan,
it seems that the machine is a sticky emotional
tangle.  It's not a ghost. It's
a murder device created by a female police officer to kill Kinnao Terada.
If you put out the image of the culprit, it's the same even if you identify the culprit
The flow of the bulletin board changed all at once.
If so, why
not? Did you notice?